ganz interessant sie teilen mit ricardo
lange eine erfahrung sie beide haben
versucht den kontakt mit dem
gesundheitsminister zu kriegen
bei ihnen hat funktioniert war lange
sehr lange nicht hinter dem mann
unbedeutend sind dann hat der kleine
krankenpfleger von unten da wird er
jetzt sparen natürlich nicht gleich
antworten aber jetzt hat es letztendlich
doch geklappt aber sie haben immer
wieder versucht im kontakt mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister zu treten
warum was wollten sie los werden also
mich stört schon seit langem dass das
gesundheitssystem so ist wie es jetzt
gerade ist dass kliniken privatisiert
wurden also momentan sind der kliniken
eigentlich eher fabriken wo die ware
menschen ankommt und da wird geld
generiert bis zum letzten atemzug aber
den kliniken bleibt daher nichts anders
übrig war sind wirtschaftsunternehmen
und die müssen schwarze zahlen schreiben
und wenn sie eben nicht wirtschaftlich
arbeiten dann gehen diese kliniken zum
teil pleite oder haben große probleme
und da wird dann halt immer ein mensch
gespart am personal gespart und dann
fingen die pandemie an wollten für mich
unbegreiflich dass ein land wie
deutschland keine masken besorgen kann
um die mitarbeiter zu schützen
diese gesichtsschutz wie sie ihre war
nicht lieferbar die haben wir krank
pflegekräfte aus wie rohmaterialen
zusammen gebastelt oder was gegen viele
industriestaaten wie deutschland ist
nicht schafft so eine simple so ein
simples visier herzustellen ist
eigentlich schon peinlich was sie sagen
und damit hat doch jetzt musste mit den
herren bundesgesundheitsminister mal
sprechen und habe ihn dann mal zum
probearbeiten eingeladen und hat
natürlich der tagesspiegel aufgegriffen
mal groß in der presse auf der
titelseite keine reaktion operativ
locker gelassen habe immer wieder
nachgebohrt und bei unangenehmen du bist
schon ab und zu und dann war ja diese
sache mit den schauspielern da hat der
herr sparen den herren lief es ja ein
gesprächsangebot gemacht und da hat sich
erste genervt dass sie das genervt dass
das dann so schnell da weil eben dieses
ganze krumm klatschen immer das hat mich
einfach genau war immer eine klatsche
danke liebe pflege danke aber wenn dann
keine taten folgen und wenn er dann noch
nicht mal auf so ne aufrufe reagiert ich
hab ja auch e-mails geschrieben da ging
es zum beispiel ums impfen
und ich arbeite ja selber einer
leiharbeitsfirma und uns hat man
bürokratisch komplett vergessen es nicht
der impfstoff war das problem sondern
das problem weil es war bürokratisch
nicht möglich einen impftermin zu
bekommen weil da muss man so ein code
und so haben das ging einfach nicht
und hatte dann bei ihm angerufen im büro
vom anrufbeantworter gesprochen und um
rückruf gebeten um hilfe gebeten weil
meine firma hat sich da seit wochen
eingesetzt hat es nicht hingekriegt auch
keine antwort und mia und kaum ist da so
ein schauspieler der mann so ein
bisschen aus der reihe tanzt und dann
wird sofort angerufen und
gesprächsbedarf und so habe ich im
tagesspiegel noch mal geschrieben
man muss es sein und laut genug schreien
dann redet damit einem und dann ja hat
er denn einen tag angerufen und hatte
sagt herr lange bekommen bei der
bundespressekonferenz so zusammen schutz
muss man sagen gerade in diesen zeiten
hat der bundesgesundheitsminister
tatsächlich unfassbar viel zu tun
schätze ich mal aber ich verstehe ihren
frust auf einer anderen ebene wird den
verstehen wer tatsächlich und wir hören
ja ganz kurz rein es war ein paar sehr
prägnante sätze die sie dort gesagt
haben aber die hatten es tatsächlich in
sich kritisch
jeder der nicht trockene intensivstation
arbeitet jeder der nicht im privaten
umfeld davon betroffen ist sieht die
leichten verläufen oder sieht vielleicht
nur menschen die gar nicht an peter
kranken und das wiederum heißt nicht
dass es diese schweren verläufe eben
nicht gibt die intensivstation sinnvoll
und wie gesagt da gibt es keine keinen
interpretationsspielraum weil es eben
nicht nur kurven gibt das kommt und ob
obendrauf und die intensivstationen
waren vor der pandemie schon deutlich
überlastet aufgrund von personalmangel
es gibt auch intensivstation die können
nicht mal alle betten befahren weil eben
das personal nicht da ist jetzt stellen
sie sich vor sie kommen ins krankenhaus
und müssen abschied nehmen mit
mundschutz mit kittel mit handschuhen
sie haben keinen körperlichen kontakt
und auch wenn die mama noch ansprechbar
sein sollte was in den meisten fällen
leider nicht mehr ist sieht sie sie zum
letzten mal mit maske vermittelt und das
ist das letzte was sie sieht dazu kommt
dass wir pflegekräfte wenn die patienten
dann leider verstorben sind eben diese
menschen wieder zum infektionsschutz in
schwarze plastiksäcke packen müssen
wir legen sie dort hinein und ziehen den
reißverschluss und glauben sie mir wenn
ich ihnen sage das macht was mit einem
was macht das mit einem
sie müssen sich vorstellen mein problem
ist ja immer dass sie patienten liegen
ja wochenlang also viele denken da kommt
ein vogel krank oder liegt in zwei drei
tagen der woche aber den link ja ewig da
und das eben kommt dann haben dazu dass
die familie die patienten eben nicht
besuchen darf also über dem wir ja quasi
die vermittlung telefonieren mit den
kindern mit den eltern und betreut den
patienten der wochenlangen kämpft ums
leben dieser patienten hier wirklich
teilweise sehr schwer krank sind und
dann kommt der tag wo man es eben doch
nicht schafft und früher war meine
meinen umgang mit sterbenden patienten
so dass man selber noch mal abschied
genommen hat also ich habe die patienten
die dann verstorben sind noch so
behandelt als würden sie noch leben habe
sie quasi noch mal zurecht gemacht aber
eben nicht grob weil er jetzt nicht mehr
da ist sondern wirklich noch ganz
gefühlvoll einfach damit man für sich
selber einen sauberen abschluss hat und
jetzt nimmt man diese verstorbenen taxi
ins schwarze plastiksäcke und wenn man
so eine erfahrung noch nie gemacht hat
sie schon schwierig aber damit man sich
vorstelle man dreht ihn herum legt dann
in den sarg macht den recherchen dazu
das ist irgendwie so unwürdig also sie
fühlt sich das was ich suche ja ethisch
an
wir machen ja auch sonst fenster auf und
so diese ganzen dinge dieser aberglaube
der dahinter steckt und das fällt ja
dann alles weg und damit kann man dann
eben nicht so gut mehr damit umgehen wie
vor der pandemie und wenn man dann noch
zuschriften bekommt man hätte den
falschen job
aber dann mich dazu meter geäußert dass
man sich emotional mitnimmt da wurde mir
mitgeteilt ich hätte den falschen job
bei einem mann der müll nicht in säcke
packen kann hat eben den falschen beruf
und das ist ja nochmal on top obendrauf
man denkt was mit der gesellschaft los
es ist schon diese verrohung die sie
gereizt halten da die dahinter steckt
die contipark hätten gerade hat ein sehr
interessantes buch zu dem thema gemacht
die shitstorm republik deutschland das
geht genau in diese richtung ganz genau
habe ich auch gerade dran gedacht also
ich höre solcher sätze ich merke an mir
selber ich bin noch nicht so verroht
dass es mich nicht immer noch entsetzt
so was zu hören gleichzeitig denke ich
aber ja klar natürlich genau das ist das
egal wie sehr man selber schon
abgehärtet ist durch die sozialen medien
ist kommt noch immer wieder irgendwas wo
man denkt dass man echt nicht wahr sein
also die
enthemmung ist da wahnsinnig
vorangeschritten
das heißt der lange die die die
verschwörungstheorien usw
das trifft auch sie mit voller wucht sie
wollen jetzt zum beispiel bei der
bundespressekonferenz habe ich mich ja
kritisch geäußert da wo dann natürlich
auch gleich von verschiedenen
gruppierungen im video draus gemacht was
so ein bisschen an der ecke drängt aber
ja selben gebiet gar keinen spielraum
aber es heißt die haben nicht also was
wir kriegen nachrichten zum beispiel ich
habe gesagt und das ist und dazu stieg
auch das intensivstation vor
corona schon voll waren also die leute
denken sozusagen als beleg dafür dass
alles gar nicht so schlimm ist weil
eigentlich waren die intensiven
harmonisch und freiheit nicht verstanden
dass die intensivstation schon vor jahr
voll waren weil es gibt ja nicht nur
peter kranke es gibt ja schlaganfälle
verkehrsunfälle suizid suizidversuche
und jetzt kommt noch diese pandemie dazu
und wenn man der intensivstation hat
sagen wir mal 30 betten die sind regulär
mit 27 patienten belegt jetzt kommt zum
beispiel zehn patienten auf die
intensivstation zu sind drei betten
verfügbar und der rest muss woanders hin
und das ist genau das problem dieser
pandemie dass diese patienten die kein
kapital in andere bereiche verlegt
werden wo sie vom personal betreuen
werden liegen nicht ausgebildet sind und
nicht geschult sind im umgang mit
intensiv richtigen patienten also
bestimmt ist dass es leute gibt die
ihnen unterstellen da legen gar keine
kann ihren wirklichen menschen drin
keine echten menschen
also kriegt äußere michael öfter mal
über corona und so unterkritisch
zuschriften habe ich auch alle apotheker
führt das alles quatsch da liege nebels
puppen im bett oder eben corona faschist
und nürnberg 2.0 wartet auf mich also es
wirklich damit kann ich noch umgehen da
also ich werde auch beleidigt wird es
die wörter hier nicht nennen aber mit
dem klasse sagt und mit dem man dieser
vergleich spitze um dinge die treffen
mich weil ich dann immer denke was ist
mit den menschen los also wir reden ja
immer von zahlen da die inzidenz ahlen
todeszahlen zahlen sind abstrakt aber
wenn es einen selber trifft dann ist
eine zahl greifbar
greift ein land das ihn nicht mehr
loslässt wenn sich mama ist der papa ist
oder man vielleicht selber betroffen ist
die situation scheint sich ja
glücklicherweise ein bisschen zu
entspannen die die impfungen scheinen zu
wirken tatsächlich also der mittlerweile
fast ein drittel des landes ist ja erst
gilt zumindest schon mal wie hat sich
das bei ihnen auf der intensivstation
aus gewährt welche leute liegen da jetzt
was hat sich verändert liegen die länger
dort weil es jüngere menschen sind die
sozusagen länger dem virus widerstand
leistung am ende vielleicht doch zu
verstärken was hat sich verändert also
die also man denkt ja mal liegen nur
alte patientin ab 80 90 aber mir also
ich hab jetzt keine statistik dann
müssten sie ja wieder fragen aber
auffällig für mich persönlich sind die
so ab 50 also wo man wie gesagt ist es
ist gehäuft hatten aber auch schon eine
28 jährige schwangere die sich so
verschlechtert dass sie dieses baby
holen musste an der fünfundzwanzigste
woche und mussten diese junge frau dann
auf dem bauch drehen also die wird den
nacken gelegt die berüchtigte bauchlage
ja gerne auch die berichte aber auch
lage genau und diese frau war wieder vor
erkrankt noch übergewichtig noch
sonstwas sind natürlich jetzt nicht die
häufigsten fälle aber es gibt es eben
auch weil die leute immer denken jetzt
trifft man die alten und schwachen dem
ist aber leider nicht so
das ist ja das perfide an dieser
krankheiten du hast du nie genau weißt
was du kriegst zwischen 0 symptomen und
tod ist alles drin
das ist der entscheidende punkt wird
sich ja noch was anderes fragen auf
einer intensivstation spitzen sich ja
dinge entweder zu oder entspannen sich
im sinne von man kann beobachten ob
einer langsam wieder zurück kommt oder
ob es tatsächlich bergab geht ob es dem
ende entgegengeht bei profit habe ich
immer das gefühl du kannst bist 18
hast du eine situation die stabil wirkt
und menschen glauben sie sind eine viel
gesünder als sie tatsächlich sind und
plötzlich kippt das ganze und die leute
sind tot wie gehen sie damit um
ich hatte mein erster fall weil ich nie
vergessen erster corona toter quasi war
einfacher ansprechbarer patient da war
ich weiß mir genau um die 60 er hatte so
ein bisschen sauerstoff in der nase
haben uns unterhalten und haben über
familie familiäre dinge gesprochen die
sich in der bundespressekonferenz gesagt
habe und habe ich dann mit ihnen von ihm
verabschiedet und gesagt wir sind es ja
dann morgen so wird alles gut ich bin
morgen wieder zum frühdienst com und der
patient war nicht mehr da weil er und
ich habe gedacht dass verlegt worden da
so gut da haben wir auf normalstation
verlegt
der ist über nacht gestorben weil er sie
so verschlechtert hat und natürlich
erlebt meistens sind diese patienten die
so schnell vorstellen dann auch schon
ein bisschen vor erkrankten aber
trotzdem ist das dann stand immer ein
schockierend weil normalerweise wie sehr
schön sagt dann kann man denn so ein
bisschen so vor an ok hier genau es gibt
eine tendenz in der tendenz aber diese
tendenz ist diesmal oft völlig weg vom
modell krasser wir haben zum beispiel
eine mama gehabt die war da war die
einzige patientin die nicht auf dem
bauch gedreht wurde war eigentlich die
stabilste von der ganzen station war
aber letztendlich die die an der ecke
musste und wo man dann muss diese
praktisch die die lunge außerhalb des
eigenen genossen also genau gibt das
letzte was sie haben das letzte was man
hat ja und war übrigens auch im dezember
auch alle ecken muss in berlin belegt
kurzer zeit mal
und ja und dann war diese an der ecke
und musste dann leider von uns gehen
weil es eben nicht geschafft hat also da
hätte man gedacht von einer tendenziell
alt
die war so um die mitte 50 und man hätte
gedacht geschafft
das ist überhaupt kein problem man man
man denkt er dann auch so und dann ist
man völlig erschrocken das ist eben doch
anders kommt wir hatten neulich jemand
hier das ähnlich berichtete der sagte
ich sehe patienten die haben die
sauerstoffsättigung die katastrophale
ist und die regen mit mir
ich denke meinte die dürfte gar nicht
mehr mit mir sprechen dass dazu dürfte
die gar nicht in der lage sein aber das
ist das tückische auch in diesem virus
die dass sich viele dinge so zugespitzt
haben also auch dieser diese frustration
von der sie berichten hat das auch was
mit personalmangel zu tun mit
chronischer überlastung über viele jahre
hinweg
also das ist ja dann würde ich mal sagen
die intensivstation man vorher schon
überlastete personal arbeitet schon an
der belastungsgrenze seit jahren und ich
kann ihnen mal ein beispiel an wie
gefährlich personalmangel ist wir machen
es ja nicht für uns ich sitze nicht für
mich hier sondern sitze auch für die
patienten hierfür die verantwortung habe
und wir als pflegekraft haben uns so
emotional erpressbar gemacht sie müssen
sich vorstellen sie haben drei patienten
eigentlich von ihnen sparen vorgegeben
2% und unterstütze ich auch dass eine
intensiv kraft zwei patienten betreut
weil da sind beatmungsgeräte dialysen
menge zeug was man beachten muss
jetzt haben die drei patienten ein
patient liegt den einzelnen und die
anderen beiden
in einem andern sie sind bei den anderen
beiden patienten drin waschen machen
bauchlage geben medikamente und der
dritte patient in einem anderen zimmer
als wach und der ist aber so schlecht
von der lunge dass er nicht integriert
ist hat aber eine beatmungsmaschine über
mund und nase geschnallt und die
unterstützt ihn bei der atmung
es kann ja jeder also macht den
selbstversuch zu hause machen war die
luft anhalten mal sehen wie lange
erschafft man irgendwann ab minute
kriegt man so eine duftnote einfach
wieder anfängt zu atmen nun alles ist
gut aber genau an diesem punkt kann der
patient eben nicht atmen sondern kriegt
einfach keine luft eben in einem anderen
zimmer was macht der patient genau wie
jemand der man trinken ist japanisch
jeder rettungsschwimmer kennt der
patient japanisch nervös reicht sich die
maske ab weil er ja denkt er hat luftnot
und etwas vor dem mund behindert ihn
daran reizt sie ab leider passiert es
dann auch häufig oder manchmal dass eben
dieser sättigung skript von dem sie
gerade gesprochen haben abgeht das heißt
der monitor erkennt nicht mehr dass die
sättigung fällt er keine luft bekommt
ich im anderen zimmer bekommen nur das
signal der sättigung skript ist passiert
bei wachen patienten häufiger und wieder
rettungsschwimmer das beispiel krieg der
rettungsschwimmer es in dem fall nicht
mit das hinter ihm jemand ins wasser
fällt war dass ich um zwei andere
kümmern muss und irgendwann wenn man
fertig es geht man im zimmer weil man ja
gucken wie menschen wieder glücksrad und
der liegt der patient leblos im bett und
man beginnt mit der wiederbelebung
mannschaft man kommt trotzdem nach hause
und fühlt sich einfach schlecht weil es
ist mein patient gewesen auf denen
vergehen recht verantwortlich war und
aufgrund von personalmangel muss ich zu
hause sitzen damit kommt man hätte
vielleicht früher merken können hättest
du vielleicht anders aber man kann ja
nichts dafür
also klar ich habe oft gesagt für mich
ist das nicht emotionale ablesbarkeit
sondern ist für mich sogar schon
emotionale vergewaltigung ist ein hartes
wort aber genau so fühlte sich einfach
an wenn man mit diesem jahr mit diesem
schicksal dann zu hause sitzt einfach
weil personalmangel war und auch die
kollegen draußen ihre patienten betreut
habe und es hat niemand mitbekommen die
sind ja auch zu also ist ja aufgrund der
infektion ist ja klar das ist das
infektionsgeschehen die türen einfach zu
bekennen das kriegt niemand
der patient liegt alleine da wir sind
extreme beispiele noch mal ganz anders
ihre mutter liegt im krankenhaus und
macht unter sich war der häufig
patienten machen und muss stundenlang in
den eigenen ausscheidungen liegen weil
kein
personal da ist was ja hilft und da ist
einfach personalmangel so schlimm ich
verstehe einfach nicht dass die
bundesregierungen da von elian spahn
sprach letztens in der pressekonferenz
von einem marathon bis da veränderungen
kommen also die ganzen maßnahmen zum
infektionsschutz also sprich ausgangs
beschränkung und so weiter wurden ja
sofort durchgesetzt aber da was ja auch
patienten gefährdet ist macht man nichts
und ich sage ihnen ich sonst irgendwas
uns auf die füße fallen wird ist diese
sache mit dem multiresistenten keim wir
haben ja probleme mit multinationalen
heim wo an die blue thema das wir auch
schon seit vielen jahren tatsächlich
sprechen genau man da passiert auch
nichts das ist max dort kommen muss das
ist auch der grund teil eines verstehe
ich warum sie im vorfeld gesagt haben
wir haben viele leute viele kollegen
kolleginnen die tatsächlich
psychologische hilfe in anspruch nehmen
ein gefühl dafür warum das
wahrscheinlich so ist ich danke ihm sehr
herzlich